[Music]
so what's your prediction if if Bisbing
and GSP fight very interesting fight
because Bisping's been a a battle or a
warrior for a long time he's been very
active and he's very he's a very like
well honed machine right now or as GSP
he's been out of the loop for a solid
three years no competition at all
however he's been training the entire
time yeah so--but GSP is not a guy who
sits around and and gets fat and he gets
nothing done
no he's constantly training yeah but
then again he stopped because he was
having memory issues and yeah I mean he
got I had 800 plus times over the course
I was UFC Kendricks fight he got hit in
the head about 10,000 times it seemed
like he was a mess after that fight yeah
he's been a mess after a few fights yeah
you know Carlos Condit head kicked him
he knocked him down I mean he's got some
Wars Matt Serra knocked him out you know
it's weird it feels like GSP he's been
the champion but it doesn't feel like
he's doesn't have that champion respect
for whatever reason well it's because
his last fight with Hendricks was super
close yeah we watch that here show I did
the fight companion no not to that fight
I was there for that fight Hendricks
yeah not Hendricks last fight I'm
talking about GSP 's last fight oh I was
talking about biz being his oh no
Bisbing and Henderson Henderson
that's when Eddie Bravo went full Tower
seven and he got super drunk was worried
the Illuminati was going to come and get
us
but and I said knockouts were better
than submissions I think well a lot of
people liked it but G ESPYs last fight
with Johny Hendricks never closed a
super close fight and GSP retired with
the belt yeah I thought I thought he
lost that fight just I mean a lot of
people did yeah a lot of people did yeah
either way it wasn't like this big
victory it's not like the way he beat
down BJ Penn and stopped him and it's
not if he said then I'm gonna retire I
had a great time thank you very much
everybody would blood yeah we love you
George
right
but instead it was a close fight some
people like hmm yeah I don't know man I
don't know if he got the belt right
maybe maybe she went out with a loss
there who knows but but don't you think
Bisbing doesn't have that championship
type respect he does not right now yeah
and the reason he does not it's because
he defended against Henderson wasn't
really ranked that high right and he
really shouldn't have got a title shot
but it was a rematch one of the most
epic knockouts ever
yes Henderson flatlined him and then
punched him in the head while he was
down and flew through the air and that's
Henderson's logo now yeah Henderson's
logo is literally a silhouette of his
body flying through the air ready to
drop a punch down on Bisping's
unconscious body yeah so and then who
else has he defended then he defended it
after he did that he in fact he's just
fine no he's fighting GSP that's the
next fight so he defended it against
Henderson and then the next title
defense is gonna be against GSP he
didn't have one before Henderson no no
he won the title by beating Luke Ross
Luke yeah and against Dan Henderson
yeah I was gonna fight chess piece oh
yeah I see this the thought is how is
this guy getting two fights that aren't
right Luke I mean will you look at
number one contender rock cold
Yoel Romero who's lever one contender it
was [ __ ] terrifying he should get the
shot yes Yoel should get this yeah yes
yeah if you look at it in terms of who's
the most viable contender who's the guy
that you would think would be the most
threatening guy who's the guy that might
be the uncrowned champion yeah you got
to go with you all Romero it feels like
UFC is I think you know they're trying
to find their way there footing a little
bit with no Rhonda and O'Connor know so
they're just going after that big what
can we sell a bunch of pay-per-views for
Angie ESPYs a big name well don't go
please go
no just ask - what's happening with
Conor and that whole fight with Floyd
Mayweather yeah no it has not been
worked out yet so it's not definitive
but there's so much money involved they
think they're gonna make it happen and
that's and that's the the UFC's got to
come to an agreement what didn't he get
in trouble with you see though Connor
didn't Connor for four I don't know not
saying something and coming out and
saying
some a while ago or get fined or
something yeah fine for the for the
throw in the water bottle yeah oh gee
thing yeah they find him 150 grand then
they dropped it down
I think they dropped up to like 35,000
he said he'd never fight in Vegas again
after that and so yeah and no I can't
you realize New York it's yeah debacle
did the big factors another factor is
also that the UFC was purchased by WMA
that's not that's a entertainment
company right entertainment companies
gonna try to put on the biggest show
they could put on and that's not
necessarily like the number one ranked
contender fighting for the title I think
that it's an entertainment I understand
it's a business I understand but it is
also there's it's extremely important
that you honor the hierarchy of champion
and top challenger I think that's
critical well you work your way up
I mean you pay your dues you work your
way up you it's you're ranked on ability
yeah
so they're trying to manufacture big
fights instead of letting big fights
yeah themselves solve yeah build big
fights evolve when you let a guy like
you over Mero fight and he wins beats
Chris Weidman by knockout and then if
you fights Michael Bisping and Michael
B's to missing Michael Bisping btol
Romero Michael Bisping becomes a
superstar right you know and it's a
tough fight it's a real tough fight if
Yoel Romero beats Michael Bisping first
of all he looks like a goddamn superhero
yeah that's easy to sell you know you
look at his highlight reel of smashing
people to the [ __ ] moon yeah as a
freak yeah he's one of the greatest
wrestlers it's ever competed you know he
he meddled in every single international
competition he entered he beat kale
Sanderson's when the greatest wrestles
of all time he beat him twice
mmm-hmm he's just a freak of freaks do
you know yellow Romero's Jamie pull up a
picture of Yoel Romero because he
doesn't even look real
no he doesn't he's like one of those
guys like what is that that's a person
is that a real person or a CGI person
just so jacked who did he oh he beat uh
he beat everybody no no but not last one
with the flying knee Chris Weidman right
oh my god he flatlined him yeah cuz it
seemed like that whole fight he wasn't
really doing much ladies
get the [ __ ] outta ya that's a real
person but he did this fund this jacked
this the fight against Chris Weidman was
sort of like hanging in the balance and
then he did some flying yeah hit him in
the side of the head yeah I feel like
where did that come from so pull up that
video that gyro Romero Kos my Chris
Weidman yeah yeah there's an animated
gif that here we go go to the video it's
[ __ ] insane like look out even how he
he [ __ ] all eyes when he lands but
look how he turns around already of lads
punches here it goes watch this boom how
recent was this fan
uh a couple months ago I was in
Australia I think I saw down there he's
just a freak and it cut the biggest gash
on the side of his head yeah see if you
got a clear video of it Superman fly
yeah I'm like another angle but he's
just uh yeah a freak of nature and
that's that's that's Cape he's capable
of that it was a second boom
but like the amount of force behind that
I just flying through the air and that's
like so irregular too it's kind of like
the way like Chuck Liddell used to hit
like real irregular like an e flying me
well he's just so he's so explosive so
his ability to close the distance is
stunning sometimes and people aren't
prepared for it because he's such an
athlete but in that fight it didn't feel
like he had been doing much you know
what I mean it feel like huge just kind
of like when is he gonna get off it was
a close fight for sure and then all of a
sudden just some out of nowhere yeah so
whether or not I mean if whether or not
Michael Bisping can beat him like who
knows but he's you got to give him a
chance
oh I know he did give you all a chance
yeah so it seems I don't know it doesn't
seem who life isn't fair who cares but
it doesn't seem fair that it's GSP well
the thing is is it a sport or is it
entertainment I mean you're just trying
to put on a spectacle or is it a sport
and if it's a sport if you're gonna have
the World Series people play this guy to
play that guy and they gets to the World
Series and here's the world's here
folks and this is we've got all this
whole season we've been building to this
moment and this is the hierarchy right
and it's still huge well if it's just a
show you put three of them in there put
you all in there too with GSP and
Michael's bit Bisbing I was saying all
three I was saying that they should have
because you're dealing with a guy in GSP
he's been out for a long time yeah have
him fight Nick Diaz he's been out for a
long time do neither one of them's
ranked they are both jobs before right
yeah yeah have a rematch yeah that's the
fight that would get ton a ton of
pay-per-view people people love Diaz
they love him I don't think people even
know how much people love them I don't
even know if the UFC knows how big of a
star Nick and Nate are yeah
[Applause]
[Music]